ce procès en appel de pascal jardin est
il un procès pour rien au terme de sept
jours d'audience on peut se poser la
question en première instance monsieur
jardin été condamné à la perpétuité avec
une peine de sûreté de 20 ans pour le
meurtre et le viol de christelle blétry
le visionnage de ces aveux détaillés et
la présence de son adn sur les vêtements
de la victime avait pesé lourd dans le
premier verdict de même sa version d'une
relation sexuelle consentie avec la
victime n'avait pas été jugée crédible
sur tous ces points d'un procès à
l'autre rien n'a changé nous attendait
peut-être à des aveux on s'attendait à
des explications
et puis il reste enfermé dans dans une
version impossible incroyable tout le
monde vient lui dire ça n'est pas
possible sans son ex femme
les expertises et psychiatres les
experts psychologues
tous ceux qui connaissent christelle
disent que ce que raconte pascal jardin
ça n'est pas possible et pascal jardin
raconte toujours la même histoire en
faisant appel pascal jardin était
évidemment dans son droit mais si ce
second procès n'apporte rien en revanche
ils constituent une nouvelle épreuve
pour les proches de christelle c'est
pour la famille terrible faire revivre
ça c'est d'une le ressens comme une
profonde douleur
peut-être que la cour d'assises en tout
cas nous lui demanderons tiendra compte
dans son verdict de du fait que cette
deuxième fois imposé imposé à la famille
alors que la version
pascal jardin ne tient pas la route est
absolument insupportable
il y a pourtant une différence entre les
deux procès en janvier 2017
les défenseurs de pascal jardin avait
semblé tétanisés par l'ampleur de la
tâche
aujourd'hui maître nicole et varley se
montre plus pugnaces mais ils sont tout
aussi démuni